good morning John it's Tuesday I don't
care what the date is I think it's very
likely that our Brotherhood will not
survive your slander of showbiz pizza's
Raqqa fire explosion band for those of
you who don't know the Raqqa fire
explosion was an animatronic band but
not just any animatronic band they were
likely the premiere form of new media of
the 1980s which probably says more about
the 1980s than it does about the rock
fire explosion but the Raqqa fire
explosion was something the world has
never seen and will probably never see
again except on YouTube clips yes it's
true old Raqqa fire explosion sets were
purchased by fans and they were
programmed to sing songs like my hips
don't lie and love in the club and this
is something that I never would have
known if John had not called me out on
my love of the rock fire explosion but
in all honesty I really do believe the
rocket fire explosion created great
music and I will not rescind my love for
they say it's your birthday though I'm
not sure that that was the song that I
had on the the LP that I got whoa if
you're wondering that's the Neue that
gets made when I start Firefox back up
with all the tabs that I had when I
closed it so all the YouTube clips that
I had open all started playing at the
same time and my processor overheated
computer the lead keyboard gorilla fat's
Geronimo and and the drummer who played
a real drum set
Duke LaRue I was a big fan of Duke Blue
as you might imagine and there's mitzi
mozzarella who I have a cup of with hens
in it Mitzi she's not a very attractive
Mouse and Beach bear and loony bird and
Billy Bob broccoli this is obviously
something that in today's world is not
very interesting but the fact that the
world can come together and create an
animatronic band that would then sing
its own original songs and each of the
characters will have their own
personalities it was like a cartoon show
but real her I don't know but I wish I
had that old birthday LP and John I'm
not taking it back and just because John
Lennon was shot doesn't mean I don't
like the Beatles and just because
Showbiz Pizza doesn't exist anymore
doesn't mean that I don't like the
rocket fire explosion that's where I
stay on this issue and I will remain
standing here I will remind you of what
you said last night after I showed you
some rocket fire explosion videos quote
I mean I can hardly believe it it's so
beautiful
I'm talking about this video is
dedicated to fat's Geronimo and just so
you know this video isn't entirely about
the rocket fire explosion band John and
nerdfighters - I want you to check out
in community channels most recent video
there's a surprise for you there I
didn't know about this she almost licked
you and if that's not enough of a teaser
I don't know what is and if you're just
judge them for a little bit more Hank
green I got two new things up at the FT
be a records that's youtube.com slash
dftba records is me singing and playing
in there and be giants song and there's
me giving an instructional video on how
to play book eight and now prepare
yourself for the new outro
[Music]